одяг врятували
я дещо траплялося на інтерв'ю щоб
бути президентом щоб ти президент розум
потрібно мати і онук політичну
програму обидва впали точних
публіці якого часу людей всередині йому це
сили не рвіться ви спрямовувати зокрема
для початку ну так-то ви знаєте що
президент ватс ап овена буде атака люди
на екрані заразна потреби визнано
ідея винен за початкова ти
нові задкувати можливо інші кермо дай
для села на клаві жертвувала знижками
пішов кандидату в президенти як би їмо
сказав ще ти вибуваєш термін
президентом all описати це бойовий вас
кого розстріляти і база варіанті
скільки б у нас була кандидата
стиль якихось дій любити україну
без і складіть ось мені хочеться обмацуючи
куща у нас думки народ я по стопу на
сенс і любеке йдуть та лади ви завели про
тому що необхідно проводити ви заявила
ще науки дна в ступор йому з лідером
і не викликаних республік днр і лнр
це вкрай негатив прийняв і в край
негативно в Україні чому ви поважаєте
за накидні труби то їм необхідно це
робити я не можу право не рубай ти-то че
споживана моно роду мого народу за
три dmr так щоразу нас багато більше
багато злоби намба ту 21 рідному проба
чат і ненависть з міс темпл навіть ті
тому пояснювала колись уже
ще написав його нею на мати для багаття
то єдиного сцена на vine та вона написала
ще б я виїжджала чим треба ж хочеш я
вижила калігули валу і ви на сказав ще
вона готова говорить і може розуміти
цю матір і
який витрачала свою дитину стогу боці так
ще люди великих у жителя пісної боже і
злодії в результаті однорідному місті то я до
морю справа край такого йти хто не
був на ведення не ходимо на провину нічого
олег витрати і називається там
диван невельська а то я допомогою рамочки
записана програма до тіла та
що й ділянки ламайте будинки до нашої
можете мої слова ж не буде прямо тут
а таких за раз критична як у вічка